well we are learning new details in the
murder investigation of destiny jackson
her family speaking at channel 8 about
getting justice for the 24 year old
woman christian costas joins us live
with more on what her family is saying
well brian the family of destiny jackson
says they are heartbroken over her death
but discovering the suspect's motive
just shatters their hearts all over
again
now we finally know exactly what
happened and
it's just really hard to
grasp all that information a grim new
reality for destiny jackson's family as
they learned more details about her
death now that we have this info and we
see that this was all by chance that
this guy
took her life
and
all for the means of to steal her car
because he wanted to get back to la
it like shatters our hearts all over
again because it's like
you really you really stole her from us
you really stole her life the i-team
learned 21-year-old albert montero was
taken into custody in california after a
brief chase with police he has allegedly
confessed to the crime after
investigators found jackson's body in
the desert near sloan earlier this month
it's a roller coaster of emotions it
comes in waves we love you and we miss
you family and friends gathered on
saturday where the young woman's body
was found to remember her an arrest
report shows montero and jackson first
met online then in person near silverado
ranch
this much of justice that we're looking
for
i mean how do you even answer for that
how do you deem what's enough justice
for what he did to her
during the police chase in l.a officers
say they found two guns and blood inside
the victim's car that montero was
driving he will be brought back to las
vegas to face charges including open
murder and robbery with the use of a
deadly weapon christian casadas 8 news
now